what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water I have with me the team
behind the movie a thousand and one huge
congratulations on your film first
feature that's something special and
excellent performances across the board
congratulations thank you all right so
clearly I know what your movie is about
are a lot of our viewers will not know
what 1001 is just yet so would you mind
doing the honors and giving a brief
synopsis
brief synopsis 1001 is the story of a
mother and son in 90s and early 2000s
New York who are she's so sweet and
thoughtful this is the mama right here
right now
um but basically you see this mother and
son Duo trying to rebuild their life in
a city that's rapidly changing around
them
um and she just so happens to kidnap
kidnap him out of foster care to do so
so again first feature is a very very
big deal when you go into wanting to
make your first movie What did you at
the time think was the first step to
making that a reality and having gone
through it is that a first step you
would recommend to some someone else or
did you find something that was more
effective
what is the first step to making a
feature film a reality yeah well I mean
you got to have the idea that you're
really passionate about
um and I think that's like very simple
but it's also really critical because
you have to climb so many mountains in
order to get to where we are today and
you have to believe in it through and
through you know during every moment
that like you're questioning life in
general like how do I get this movie
done and made and out the door to share
with audiences you really have to
believe in it because it's going to ask
everything of you you know
um and so you have to be in it 100 to
follow up on that and everyone can chime
in on this making a movie is a feat no
matter how much you plan no matter how
many resources you have there are ups
and downs can you each pinpoint a low
point in the making of This film where
you thought like maybe I won't be able
to pull it off maybe I can't do it and
then where you found that confidence to
overcome that challenge and see the
thing through to fruition
AV give the best hugs
honestly she really do and she kept us
protected
um I went during my lunch break three
different lunch breaks I've been to
three different funerals in weeks so I
was dealing like a lot of death uh
losing friends in Harlem and it was just
like to come back to set like okay how
am I gonna like pull this together and
get it and it's just like she would see
what I'm even having to tell her what
was going on and she'd give me a hug and
I cried you know and then we get to it
you know and she make me use whatever it
is that it's in my heart and what I'm
feeling and she make me put it into the
scene so I was able to Channel all my
energy through Inez you know seriously
can't undervalue the uh the impact of a
good hug I'm a big believer in the truth
in that I'm not making light of it like
a hug even like just without it doesn't
matter what it's about you know is about
like whatever it is you're going through
whether it's my business or not you know
what I'm saying like this is what we're
gonna do that goes a long way you know
like nothing has to be said not a word
Yeah Yeah because sometimes or a lot of
times where it just aren't enough yeah
all right well what about for you a low
Point how'd you overcome it a low Point
[Music]
um
I think I emailed AV and said uh
can we talk and then we went to or she
emailed me actually yeah she emailed me
it's like can we talk and uh we went to
a restaurant and I simply said I don't
know if I'm the guy you want
and um she's like no you are the guy I
want that's why you're here
and I just want to tweak some things and
then on top of that you know I'm coming
to New York I'm for some odd reason
because I do the audition I'm from DC
I'm not really from New York and it's
like oh you need this accent so I'm like
oh
accent AV wants to talk
um okay so that was going to be a low
moment for me but then I hired a dialect
coach and then when me and AV sat down
and and got a chance to talk I
understood her Rhythm and what she was
trying to do so there's some things that
I wanted to do that I had to surrender
to her vision and what she wanted to do
you know so it was it was a beautiful
moment that became a high because when
we fast forward to a scene that we do an
intimate scene that we're doing and at
this point
we're talking with our words I'm looking
and I said let me try something and it
was something in the scene that was
needed that was not there and had we not
had those moments then that trust
wouldn't have been there in that moment
so I needed that low moment for the
other moment to happen and uh yeah I
think we got an amazing project on our
hands that's why I asked that low
moments aren't bad it's just something
to build on and make something else
better yeah but when you get that call
from your director email like we need to
sit down I'm like oh damn
also the fact that you didn't think you
needed like he thought he had a New York
accent already like you did you didn't
think that you had a DC accent there's a
difference no no I didn't even think
about it until we was shooting the scene
but she was like now say it like this
say it like this I said oh shucks
okay let me call a dialect coach let me
call my boy Eamon from uh he from Harlem
let me get with g-dot okay let me get
that Harlem bounce baby we came back to
set I was on though yeah no he was he
was I'll give you that yeah maybe I'm
not letting you get out of that question
I want a low point in this production
you know I was actually like incredibly
burnt out after we after we wrapped
principal photography and I had never
experienced that like you know you have
little moments but I was just like
really like wow
um and so I think actually something
that really meant something to me kind
of similar to what you said about hugs
is a young lady that was a part of our
crew she sent me this really like
wonderful thoughtful care package and
she came out of the Foster system so she
had nothing no like idea of what the
story was before she joined our crew and
I think just in the process of making it
and going along this this ride with us
um she was like I feel like you told my
story and and I met so much so much to
her because she felt so seen so at a
moment where I was kind of like do I
wanna do I want to finish this do I want
to make movies I'm just so like I just I
just didn't physically have it you know
mentally have it
um I remembered why it was so important
to get this story and to get stories
like this outdoor because people just
want to feel seen you know they want to
feel understood they want to feel like
other human beings that are watching
their stories being told Will empathize
them like they empathize with our
characters so that was just like a
really visceral reminder for me for like
why I make movies in the first place I'm
jumping all over the place because I do
want to go back to the casting process
but your answer is reminding of
something else I like to ask often
because I'm a big believer that in this
industry or anywhere in the world for
that matter we don't tell people good
job nearly enough so was there ever a
time on this set when someone behind the
scenes just really crushed it at
whatever their job was and you want to
tell them like good job I appreciate
your hard work like right now tell them
yeah yeah I mean
um I mean I think everybody this was
something that I feel like it was a
production that like it was so hard to
get through like shooting in covid
shooting a movie with a small budget uh
shooting during severe weather et cetera
et cetera et cetera like and so I think
our crew like I'm immensely grateful to
them in general
um I think one shout out that I I can
think of in particular is the art team
because I was it was really important to
me to feel like this was an authentic
home for this type of woman in the 90s
and early 2000s and that's the period
that's actually not well documented in
terms of like what did black people live
like you know and so I felt like I could
describe it over and over just like the
nuances of what I remember but I didn't
have a lot of picture references
um and it was actually during our
um when we were location scouting with
my production designer and I was like
there it goes like you know just certain
people in their homes they still had
like you know the bedroom sets or like
just certain types of like leather
couches or whatever you know and so we
got our iPhones out and we got all those
documents because it's just like it's
just a lived in breathed in experience
of what I felt like I needed to see when
I thought of anybody that I was growing
like all the mommies and aunties that
would have been living like Inez you
know the plastic on the on the uh on the
lamp you know it's just like certain you
know when you thought you was living
large with certain furniture sets that
you know aren't really around now like
it was really important to get that in
the art team I was really proud of the
work that they did to get all of those
details right I'll throw that question
your way too both of you a time when a
crew member made all the difference to
you because they crushed their work and
it made a tough scene easier for you
honestly
all of the props
um scouting like everybody was really
sweet to me
um and yeah like she said the whole team
really really crushed it and it takes a
village it really do you know and us
being in front of the lens is a very
very small part of a movie maybe you
could say small but important very very
important but what I'm saying is if it's
not for the village oh for sure you know
what I'm saying hundreds if not
thousands of people are responsible for
making them exactly yeah I think what
she's tapping into is that they're even
though their part is incredibly critical
that you know movies are some of all
parts and no parts no one part is above
the whole coming together
now I'm backtracking going back to the
casting I had read somewhere that
originally you didn't think Tiana was
the obvious choice for this role so it
was making me curious what did she do in
her audition that the change that made
you say yes I have my Inez now yeah I
think I just within you know a short
audition tape I got to see the breath of
what I was looking for in terms of uh
not only what was critical in terms of
uh
performance like just the actor being
able to like really give something
honest to the scene but also just like
the authenticity that I was looking for
and feeling like I could see through her
performance that she knows this human
being in real life or she is you know
this human being in real life and in the
ways that you know I needed an actress
to really connect to the material
because I think like
you don't see a lot of that in Hollywood
you see
um you know I think like a
I didn't want to feel like it was
performative like oh let me be this
Urban woman you know this ghetto woman
or whatever you know what I'm saying
like I needed somebody who just like
that's my Auntie or that was me at a
particular age you know like and and I
think Tiana had that you know in her
innately
um and I felt like similar to me like
she has a lot of like New York just that
she like oozes out naturally and then
she just had the chops like you know
just to be able to deliver those really
difficult highs and lows of the movie
um like the joy and the pain was such
like range and that levity and and like
that you know grit that Inez had there
is a significant amount of range to your
character and we also cover like an
expansive amount of her life too of
everything she goes through is there any
particular thing you were most
intimidated to play
[Music]
um
I mean life whooped onez's ass you know
so it was it was never a moment that
like did not intimidate me but I feel
like I needed to feel that you know what
I'm saying like I don't want anything to
be easy I don't want anything to fall in
my lap you know like so it was like I
could moan and holler about
something but I'm gonna get the job done
you know what I'm saying and I needed to
I needed that fare if there's fear is
okay you know what I'm saying nothing is
wrong with fear because it puts you in
survival mode and as Inez I had to
survive you know what I'm saying so if I
didn't have that fear I wouldn't step
into survival mode I always feel like if
you don't have fear and you don't have
nerves it's probably a sign that you
don't care and you can't not care
because there's no there's no passion in
things being easy there's no passion and
feeling like you know it all you got it
all down it's like where's the passion
in that you you got to fight for
something and I'm all about the fight
you have no fight we could just never be
on the same page all right well I'm
coming your way so I feel I feel like
Inez and Terry are the main characters
of the movie you are pivotal to their
journey and then on top of that you also
have to make lucky feel like a whole
person even though we don't get the same
amount of private moments with him so is
there any backstory details that you
would have come up with yourself that we
might not hear about via dialogue or see
on screen but we can feel informing your
performance and making him whole I think
it was just him being present you know
when I watched the film some of the
looks he would give Terry the looks he
would give Inez the looks when he was on
the couch
the basketball scene you know all those
moments you know gave you his backstory
I think if there was more than it would
have took away from what was right there
in front of you lucky was a joy to play
you know I have an amazing father in my
life so a lot of things I was able to um
put into lucky but they was already
written like walk on it walk on this
walk on this side of me my dad had told
me that when I was a young man you know
you walk on this side of the street so
those things came so natural
um I just you know hats off to AV I mean
it was all on the page you know
sometimes you know when you do a lot of
projects it's not on the page and actors
great actors look for things that are
not on the page but when it's there then
that's the gift because you can just
live with what's there yeah oh so many
collaboration questions I'll I'll ask
the two of you about AV first what is
something about her as an actor's
director that made all the difference
for you on this set that you hope to
experience with more directors in the
future you're feeling protected you know
I've been saying that all day like
that's we're very very big on that
because a lot of people you know they
step behind that camera and they want
what they want and then that's that you
know but she's not going to say we got
it until everything is perfect you know
so it's like sometimes you'll be like oh
my God this was the take and then you
see the movie and it's like wait what
have it you know but it's just like she
know when she got it and she's not gonna
have nobody looking crazy you know so
it's like a trust that you have is a
vulnerability that you can have with a
person that makes you feel safe you know
it's so many different levels of
protection you know mental protection
emotional protection spiritual
protection you know and she's given us
protection all across the board and
that's a big thing for me because I've
been on a lot of sets where I have not
felt protected
for me
um you may see a five foot something
human being but that's a giant right
there and she's not going to back down
on what she wants and that artist that
authenticity reads through and so when
you have someone showing up in their
life as authentic as she is it forces
you to be authentic so she's not trying
she's not trying to prove anything you
know even doing this she's not trying to
prove anything this is what I thought
this is what I wanted to share
here it is and it's so much freedom in
that and it allows you to be free and I
thank you for that
I asked this question earlier I love
asking this question and hadn't in a
while but now I'm curious what is what
is av's like monitor dance so to speak
like something she does behind the
camera that signals to you like I like
this take we're good to move on
I know one
um I love her she bring that little
paper she got like these little these
sides and it's like it would have all
the doodling and like all these
different notes and I'm like are you
saving all of these you know what I'm
saying but it's like once again it's
that passion you know what I'm saying
and it's just like she do do this like
this little smile because she don't
really like to smile much but I know
when she happy she do this like little
like this little look and I'll be like
yeah I killed that you know what
I'm saying it's like that little you
know you just knowing she happy but
that's what I love because she's
readable you know like you know and you
know when it's like okay well TV school
try that one again you know what I'm
saying just maybe try it this way you
know so it's like this little smirk
smile thing that she does when she's
happy and she got her shot
you know like you people won't know that
I'm like super sweet and silly into I'm
like hey you know what I'm saying so
it's just like she's just like she has a
great balance and just it's also part of
being like a professional you know what
I'm saying I'm not gonna feel like I'm
doing what I got to do if she
happy-go-lucky all the time like I need
we it's time to get down to business
because she'll smile and be like all
right now back to work I love that like
she balances like making you feel
comfortable she balanced professionalism
and being family oriented she balanced
it very well so that's what I mean I'm
not saying she's unhappy yeah I would
say AV is like Coach K you know she'll
come over to me and it'll be good and
she's like yeah I want you to lean more
into that tomorrow you know so I'm like
okay okay I got it so she likes
something but we need to carry that over
to the next the next scene so um you
know as a former basketball player I I I
like that you know it's stoic with her
you know she ain't gonna let you know
too much but she'll like exactly yeah it
is like she got this swag that should be
flying set too she's like the Flies
director I've seen
I believe it too so they're singing your
Praises you've got this work down it
seems but we learned something new on
every single production so what is a new
tool in your directing toolkit so to
speak that you know you can credit to a
thousand and one that you're excited to
apply to a future film
um I mean I think I learned to be
present in a new way and on another
level and and I'm extremely grateful for
that and I think anybody who like you
know spiritual meditation that type of
stuff
um I feel like oh it clicked for me on
another level because I had to show up
in a way
um that wasn't you know active me on
prior Productions and so I'm super
grateful for that and just really
existing in the moment and what do we
need right now despite whatever level of
drama chaos or uncertainty
um and so I'm grateful for that and I
think that like with everything that I
did have to overcome and making my first
feature and all the things that I
learned from it I think it made me that
much more of a stronger filmmaker and a
stronger leader and that's really
important I think leadership the the
part of directing directing is not just
like getting what you want or what you
need but you have to be the one that is
like guiding and everyone and energizing
everyone
um and so I think just it sharpened my
tools in that respect too I don't want
to let you guys go without asking about
the teres because the three of them are
great Dan I'll throw this one to you and
I don't know if you thought about it
this specifically but can you tell me
something unique about your
collaboration with each of those actors
that maybe reflected the stage of their
relationship throughout the film
um it's crazy because I'm a mother of
two I'm always in Mommy Mode so it was
like the chemistry where all three of
them was amazing and they all had like
that respect for me so it was kind of
like just a coddling situation where
they just like naturally got up under me
and I thought that that's what made it
really dope because we it was like
mother and son with all three of them
from like start to finish they're
exceptional the whole movie is
exceptional congratulations again first
feature quite the accomplishment thank
you it's been a pleasure 1001.
congratulations to everybody out there
stay tuned we'll have more from Sundance
2023 for you soon